Yeah,
it's worth more for other fights because the whole card was so amazing.
It's going to get more people to what is your favorite card?
Favorite moment of the night.
Was it Derek Lewis?
Derrick Lewis,
Tony,
Derrick Lewis.
Derrick Lewis winning by knockout.
Yeah,
and and in a fight where he said that thing about Derrick Lewis is he can always
just land one punch and we had just got done saying that like 10 seconds before
he lands his fucking Howitzer on the top of that dude's head.
And then the post fight interview,
we say it takes his shorts off and I'm standing here,
what are you doing man?
It was my balls was hot.
I'm like,
oh my God.
But me,
I always knew Derek is hilarious.
He's always hilarious.
So I always look forward to talking to him.
But his Instagram,
if you want to know what Derrick Lewis is about,
you've got to see his Instagram and I brought that up and now he's got like,
he's got a million more than a million.
What does he at now?
500 some thousand and just a couple of days after that.
That's so awesome.
But it's true.
It's fucking,
Instagram's all motorcycle accidents do the jumping off roofs and landed on
their heads,
but it's a false fucked up Instagram of all time.
But he's just a funny dude,
man.
He's really funny and him and Daniel Cormier like them promoting a fight is
going to be a breath of fresh air because like did you see the thing where you
know like Dan,
he was joking around.
He said,
he say he's going to knock me out.
He's like,
yeah man,
he was disrespecting Popeye's.
Let's play this cause it's so funny.
Eric Lewis told me that he was going to knock me out right before we walked.
Hi
there.
What's your issue with Daniel?
I want to know too
this suspect that Popeye's chicken on it
together.
This is a bad version of it,
but
this is all music and stupid editing,
but he's just a funny guy,
man.
He's just a funny guy and he's look,
I mean,
and he joked around about it with DC.
He's like,
she at 1.3 million followers now that it's hilarious.
You just gained a million followers because I've been following him for years
now.
Yeah,
I think he gained a million followers and he,
you know,
they were talking about it and he,
and,
and he said to Daniel,
you know,
Dennis said,
he goes,
you want it,
you don't really want to hit me.
And he goes,
motherfucker,
fuck off.
Fight anybody for money.
It's just classic.
It's just a funny guy and there won't be any of that do opening nonsense,
but it'll still sell a lot because it's fun.
So a lot of Popeye's too,
it's going to sell on everything and it's going to sell a lot of everything,
but it'll definitely sell a lot of paper views.
The real question is,
is it going to be able to deal with Cormier's wrestling coronaries experiment.
This is the level of fighting that Columbia is experience is just significantly
higher.
But Derrick Lewis has unbelievable power.
I mean his power,
his fucking no joke man.
If you look at some of his Kao victories,
he's a puncher.
Brutal.
He is.
But I think if he and I,
I'm a big Derrick Lewis Fan,
but I think if he fights DC like he fought Volkov it's going to be a tough night
for him.
Um,
I know that,
I know that it could go anyway and that one shot from Derrick Lewis can put DC
out or anyone in the world out.
But I just see dcs wrestling has is dirty boxing.
I mean everything.
If,
if you,
if,
if Derrick Lewis is turning his back to DC,
like he wasn't Volkov and he's going to close the distance,
he's going to take his back,
he's going to exploit that.
He's going to take them down.
Sure.
There's a difference between six foot seven,
five foot 10 though it's true is a giant difference in size between Volkov and
DC.
DC's a real light heavyweight who in my opinion could fight and Raphael's weight
class.
I mean I think DC really got his diet in order.
He can be a one of the fiber.
It's true,
but it can flip over.
Josh Barnett over his head,
all sorts of guys.
There's something about that,
that round body type though.
I mean there really is like a barrel,
the,
you know,
the ability to kind of be ungrabbable you know,
and uh,
of course he has the power and he has the wrestling.
So I mean,
he,
he's like a version of feed or you know,
very similar,
very similar.
Seen him knock out Steve Bay with one shot.
Like that was stunning.
It's like wow.
And he was saying that he was doing that and training,
he said he hits way harder as a heavyweight.
I think just the way he likes to live his life and how he likes to eat.
He just has more energy as a heavyweight,
you know,
he might be a better down through a whole life of cutting weight.
I mean,
the entire life of it.
And uh,
how to withdraw from the Olympics because if kidney failure from weight cutting
his life should be a movie for sure.
I mean,
the way the stuff that he's overcome,
the stuff that has happened to them,
the missed opportunities and wrestling and not miss opportunities.
He was one of the,
I mean,
he's so great.
Yeah.
But not being the champion.
That being the world champion up,
being the Olympic champion and then coming to in the life stuff that he's gone
through.
Um,
I'm just happy that people like him now cause you remember he was getting booed
for so long.
She was ridiculous.
Every time he got booed,
like broke my heart.
It took a while for people to understand him.
And now I think that people,
you know,
after people seeing him choke out rumble Johnson and then seeing him knock out
Steve pay people like,
oh he's a bad motherfucker and he's a really nice guy.
He's a great dude.
One of the best commentators now.
He's hilarious.
Yeah.
That's also what,
what made him grow on people as well.
Like you hear him and commentary and you realize like he's not an EGOMANIAC.
He's a really good guy who knows a lot about fighting,
knows a lot about wrestling.
And I'm a man.
I'm so looking forward to John Jones coming back to John John's fighting
Gustafson.
That is very fascinating.
Is that going to a,
I know they're going to strip DC.
So is that,
does that fight for a title or,
yeah,
I guess interim are the real deal.
I think that's the real deal deal,
which is weird,
right?
Yeah.
Like why let the guy be champ champ if you're not going to let them.
I mean,
I dunno.
It's like,
I mean I'm a time I'm so torn on all this waste.
Probably going fight the winner anyways and then it will be for the belt.
So maybe let them keep the belt.
I mean look,
I love the UFC.
Obviously I've been working for the UFC forever,
but I think there is an obvious conflict of interest when the promoter is also
responsible for who holds titles and who gets to fight for titles.
It's weird,
you know,
I mean in every other sport there's like a sanctioning body that decides this
is,
you know,
Rafael Lovato one five fights in a row.
He's the undisputed number one contender.
He will be next in line for the title,
you know,
not,
oh Logan.
Paul's sold 5 million.
Youtube buys seeds next.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
it's weird,
like it's,
it's weird that commerce,
I mean,
it plays a giant part in any sport,
right?
But should it be the ultimate decider in what,
what happens and what doesn't happen.